es macht da rein wollte und sie sind das
ehepaar bauer wir haben hart und
gerlinde bauer unternehmens doch das
kino und sie haben heute einen termin
bei mir wegen einer scheidungsberatung
naja wir wollten eigentlich vorher schon
noch eine eine eheberatung machen ja das
freut mich dass sie da sehr optimistisch
ranking also wo sitzt ihr problem
sie streiten häufiger an das 4 2
das ist in einer ehe vielleicht auch
manchmal besser so aber da gibt es ein
paar übungen zur verbesserung der
gesprächs fitness übung 1 herr bauer
reden sie mit ihrer frau reden ja das
muss jetzt nichts großartiges
geistreiches seien ja das ist ein
leichtes tv wie wäre es zum beispiel
frau ein kompliment machen kompliment so
gut
ja du hast sehr schöne du hast sehr
schöne der studie ist sehr schön auf die
zukunft des wählen herr bauer
denn was denn erzählen sie was ihnen an
ihr besonders gefällt ja die sagen die
mir an hier früher glück vorm die sagen
jetzt teilweise an plätzen wo es früher
es heißt sich abermals an
man muss ja nicht immer reden
geheimnisse beleben die partnerschaft
regus geheimnisse lassen seit ihrer
kreativität ab bis er meint das ist bei
dieseln die tür zumachen gratis
schon mal ein anfang wie sie jetzt im
geheimen bücher oder was ist ja seit
jahren gegen die bachelor reihe und es
ist doch gut wäre ja auch von den
nebengeräuschen ganz zu schweigen sie
produkte wenn der in der für die treppe
runtergehen schüssel der la paloma zu
schaffen
muss jetzt nicht jedes detail bleibt
freilich muss man kündigt heißen muss
man geht es an die details die nur in
bayern sind immer donnerstags da wird
man sie im schlaf dann backen und wissen
wie sieht es denn aus mittel gemeinsamen
unternehmungen haben sie gemeinsame
hobbys gemeinsame freunde unternehmen
sieht man mal was gemeinsam wir geben
dienstagnachmittag im august zum
schafkopfen und ich meine gemeinsam mit
ihr die brachte bloss mit ihm morgens
mussten beim sonst was sie zeigen da
auch kein ausgesprochenes interesse der
kinder sie den 1
dann würden sie auch keinen
ausgesprochenen ist interesse daran
zeigen einer ehe muss man probleme
gemeinsam lösen
hätte ich die probleme ja da haben sie
natürlich recht aber eine ehe hat er auf
ihre schönen zeit nehmen es die alten
fotos wieder mal zur hand
lasst uns die alte romantik wieder ein
bisserl aufsteigen und mehr darunter
beiden fotos dann kommt bei mir gehen
die romantic auf wissen sie wie der
frühere haus geklettert
er war also gewarnt dagegen waren
ottfried fischer am morgen war der dacia
duster fassen und ehrlich der
fragestunde fassen was da gestand er hat
budget herr dr
die tochter mit den mut hat wie 100
jahre das sogar von jopie heesters
die praktisch nicht waschen nicht rufen
hat jeden moment habe ich sehr wohl
gewaschen werden mit waschen putzen der
menschen oder kombi swiss life science
krems hat auch immer die erstens rest
nicht hängen blieb und so lesen dresden
ja aber du hast mir ja das sind wir doch
schon beim nächsten thema die
attraktivität
das ist ganz normal dass das in einer
langjährigen partnerschaft etwas
nachlässt sich vielleicht ganz verliert
sie haben sicher probleme mit ihrem
liebesleben gehabt
sie vollziehen den liebesakt noch gut
machen
sie wissen schon wo dieser lange in
herzkamp meisten schiffe versenken
ersten stangen einen tag vor mir
das klappt bei ihnen keine frage jeden
tag geben januar als alle vier stunden
sonst gehört zum 30 berlin nachwuchs ist
verstehe ich jetzt überhaupt nicht mehr
ziehe sie unternehmen nichts gemeinsam
die haben keine gemeinsamen freundes ja
meine gemeinsamen hobbys darum haben wir
ja so viel zeit und zeit apropos zeit
langsam mehr als mittel zeit
wichtig ist jetzt dass wir sie wegen
unseren eheproblemen jetzt unter lang
aufgehalten haben wir wissen was wir im
rhythmus bleiben damit auf sie zurück
[Musik]
[Applaus]